Something really strange is happening
at White House press briefings
lately. It's almost like reporters
don't have any idea what to ask about.
And I don't want to suggest that there is nothing
to ask about. As I've talked about for weeks now,
Joe Biden's failed executive order on stopping
deportations, foreign policy questions, minimum
wage. There are plenty of things to ask about
during Jen Psaki White House press briefings.
But for some reason, reporters at press
briefings are increasingly concerned with
asking over and over and over again, why
won't you call the situation at the border
a crisis which is just this endlessly semantic
question? And yesterday, questions about Joe
Biden's dogs and possibly a cat. I'm not joking,
Joe Biden's younger dog, Major Biden, bit someone
at the White House, the person is fine. As of
yesterday, it wasn't totally clear who it was.
As of today, it seems that it was a Secret
Service agent. It was reported that Major Biden
was sort of surprised as a Secret Service agent
came around the corner or something like that,
had a minor injury treated at the White House
now after one reporter had already asked about it
yesterday. Another reporter asks a follow up and
the question is phrased in a wacky, histrionic,
dramatic way, asking whether Jen Psaki can assure
the American public that Major Biden isn't going
to be euthanized. Look at this about three things.
That's a state that, of course, dogs immigration.
And then, Governor, another dog's question. OK,
go ahead to follow. Just a quick clarification
on the dogs. OK, can you confirm that it
was a Secret Service member who was bitten?
And can you also reassure the public that Mr.
Biden will not be euthanized as a result of this?
Well, certainly, Major Biden is a member of the
family. So I can assure you that I don't have any
more details on the individual. I would encourage
you to ask the Secret Service, but I'm not going
to have any more intimate details other than that.
It's all phrased in the most histrionic and
dramatic terms possible. Jen, can you assure the
public as if the public is waiting around to know
this, that major won't be euthanized? If you have
to ask a second question about Joe Biden's dogs,
maybe it would be has the Biden family determined
how they will handle Major Biden in the future
in light of this dog bite? Like if you if you
are going to insist on asking more about it.
But can you reassure us he won't be euthanized,
just desperate to create controversy
if she had said I have no idea whether they're
going to euthanize the dog. I haven't spoken to
Joe Biden about it than the headline would
be. Jen Psaki refuses to deny that, Joe,
that Major Biden might be euthanized. And then I
guess at some point someone in the past said maybe
the Bidens will be getting a cat. And another
reporter asking about the cat, if you can imagine
questions we had about dogs, we were promised
the White House cat what happened to that?
Where is the cat today? A good day for the
cat. I don't have any update on the cat.
We know the cat will break the Internet,
but I don't have any update on its status.
So there it is literally devolving into questions
about dogs and cats. And I think part of what's
going on here part is the reporters don't
don't know what to ask about substantively.
Part of it is that we are now moving beyond the
reality TV presidency of Donald Trump. Joe Biden
isn't tweeting attacks at people all day long. Joe
Biden's administration is denouncing the press as
an institution. And it's sort of like reporters
are struggling to move beyond the reality show
that was the Trump presidency. My question to you
is, do you think they don't know what to ask or
do they think that these questions will be seen as
relevant and interesting by the American people? I
just don't even understand the motivation to ask
about a cat. Maybe don't ask a question if you
have nothing relevant to ask about. Maybe that's
part of it. Where if you're in the briefing room,
even if you have nothing to say, you want to get
a question in there. And so you ask about a cat.
I really don't have the explanation as to what's
going on, but I'd be curious to hear from you.
And we'll have more on this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page. Find us on Instagram at David
Pakman show. Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.